vous le savez les lycéens ont rejoint le
mouvement des gilets jaunes et depuis
hier tourner sur les réseaux sociaux
une vidéo que vous voyez là si vous ne
la connaissiez pas déjà avant elle
montre le regroupement 253 lycéens
interpellés par les forces de l'ordre à
la suite de violences commises en marge
des blocages au lycée saint-exupéry et
jean rostand
ça se passe à mantes-la-jolie dans les
yvelines un certain nombre de
personnalités en particulier à gauche
ont été choqués par ces images et
consultats cause c'est pas comme ça que
doit faire la police mais la police a
quand même des défenseurs à commencer
par le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer
il était ce matin sur france inter
esimit l'image est forcément choquant
que s'est-il passé hier à mantes la
jolie à mantes-la-jolie il ya des
éléments extérieurs au lycée et des
personnes de plus de 20 ans souvent qui
au cours des jours précédents avaient
accumulé des poubelles en venant les a
portés en fourgonnette qui ont coincé le
lycée qui ont réussi à rameuter quelques
lycéens pas forcément d'ailleurs du même
endroit il ya des gens qui sont venus
d'autres départements
ils ont envahi un pavillon ils ont volé
des bonbonnes de gaz
ils ont commis des exactions ils ont
évidemment attaqué les forces de l'ordre
lesquelles ont cherché à les neutraliser
et en les neutralisant les ont
effectivement mis contre un muret avec
les images que l'on voit elle avant de
vous demander votre avis je vous propose
d'écouter un témoignage de plus qui est
celui de valérie pécresse qui est la
présidente de la région ile de france
elle connaît elle connaît bien ce sujet
puisque vous savez que ce sont les
régions qui gère les lycées par là point
de vue éducatif mais en terme
d'organisation et de gestion et pour
elle c'est clair s'il ya de la violence
elle n'est pas du côté des policiers il
y a eu des violences inédites et moi je
suis inquiète pour aujourd'hui je suis
inquiète pour aujourd'hui parce que les
mots d'ordre sont clairement de faire
des démarrages de feu dans les lycées je
suis allé en seine saint denis je suis
allée auprès des proviseurs et je peux
vous dire que la situation est
extrêmement tendue donc il faut replacer
la vidéo est vide et vous venez de me
montrer dans ce contexte
d'extraordinaire tension de violence que
l'on a jamais vu même pendant les
mouvements de la loi il comme riz et
aujourd'hui je veux le dire
l'obsession des policiers c'est de ne
pas blesser un lycéen
bernard est ce que l'enseignant que vous
êtes même si c'est un enseignement
supérieur et pas au lycée a été choqué
par
ces images et vous nous avez demandé si
on était choqué par l'arrestation de
lycéens mais ce sont des lycéens se sont
joints you dire que c'est leur statut au
lieu de verser parce que ce sont des
lycéens c'est parce qu'ils font des
études secondaires qui sont lycéens mais
là ils n'ont pas été arrêtés en tant que
lycéen ils ont été arrêtés en tant que
cascadeur et donc par conséquent bien
entendu dire on ne peut pas être
satisfait je dirais que les forces de
l'ordre soit obligée d'intervenir aux
alentours des lycées c'est c'est la
preuve je dirais de ce que le tissu
social de ce que l'éducation a été raté
vous m'aviez posé la question il ya
quelques temps est ce que j'ai fait
favorables à la présence de policiers
dans des établissements c'est quelque
chose que je trouve parfaitement
ubuesque mais en revanche que des
policiers neutralisent et arrêtent des
voyous alors ça ça me paraît absolument
acceptable et même nécessaire cela dit
on peut peut-être se dire que le fait
d'avoir laissé diffuser ces images
ce serait presque un tour d'essai un
round décès avance que la police serait
autorisé à faire demain et si elle le
fait vis-à-vis de casseurs c'est très
bien si elle le fait vis-à-vis de gilet
jaune c'est plus juste mal je vais vous
demander votre point de vue mais avant
je voudrais vous donner celui de dame
internautes jean michel qui est
intéressant comme souvent les avis de
nos internautes
éduquer jugé punir même très sévèrement
oui humilié non surtout dans ce contexte
moi je crois que le il faut il faut
avoir à l'esprit que le métier de
policier est un métier difficile
en général il est encore plus
actuellement parce qu'on est dans un
climat de très grande tension
et évidemment il s'agit surtout pas de
faire d' amalgame avec de mettre toutes
les forces de police dans dans le même
sac voilà c'est pas ça mais il y a quand
même des choses si vous voulez qu'on ne
peut pas accepter
il y a des choses qui sont interdites
dans la 2 dans la technologie de la
police nationale par exemple les tirs
tendus les tirs tendus de lens bol ça
c'est quelque chose qui est totalement
interdit et il il y à de très nombreux
témoignages qui font état de ses tirs
tendus dans la journée d'hier et pas à
mantes la jolie mais dans plusieurs
comme eurent mené la police est trop
violente non je dis que quels sont les
instructions qui sont donnés aujourd'hui
aux forces de police
comment les prépare-t-on danse et
quelles sont les stratégies et les
doctrines qui sont mises en place pour
aller dans ces manifestations
qu'est ce qu'on demande exactement aux
forces de police est ce qu'on leur
demande de protéger les lycéens comme
c'est le devoir des forces de police ou
est ce qu'on leur demande autre chose je
pense que c'est ça le vrai problème qui
est posée c'est de savoir quelles sont
les instructions qui sont données et que
ce soit sur les événements des
champs-elysées où que ce soit ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui aux abords des lycées
je crois qu'il sera peut-être nécessaire
d'avoir une commission d' enquête
parlementaire pour savoir exactement
pour comprendre la manière dont tu as
été dont ont été gérés les forces de
l'ordre quels sont les instructions les
ordres qu'on leur a donné
comment est-ce que tout cela at il pu se
passer
alors il ya un internaute jack qui nous
dit est ce qu'on parle des bonbonnes de
gaz ramené par les lycéens lycées entre
guillemets en fait effectivement vous
avez raison jacques il ya eu il ya eu
cesser ces éléments extrêmement
inquiétant d'ailleurs jean-michel
blanquer
dans l'extrait qu'on vient de diffuser
de son interview à france inter de ce
matin parle de ces de ces lycéens ou
supposés tels qu'ils avaient volé des
bonbonnes de gaz et voulait des devis
dayan est ce que vous avez été choqué
par cette image écoutez le problème je
pense que si je faisais tu es un membre
des forces de l'ordre je comprendrais
pas très bien ce qu'on me demande si on
me demande de me de maîtriser les
manifestations avec un plus haut à le
faire le ménage avec juste un petit
balai comme ça c'est difficile pour eux
là en l'occurrence qu'est ce qui se
passe on dit faut protéger les lycéens
les ceux qui sont là sont des gens qui
ont manifesté violemment donc ils sont
ils ont été repris et traiter violemment
je veux dire mon vision sur les mains
ils ont les mains sur la tête
si j'étais un vieux réactionnaire je
dirais que moi à l'école il suffisait de
murmurer dans la salle pendant que le
professeur nous envoie dans un coin avec
les mains sur la tête et on leur faisait
pas toute une histoire mais là c'est
simplement pour les maîtriser pendant
quelque temps mais ça c'est le phénomène
internet
effectivement quand on voit les choses
comme ça il faut se replacer dans le
contexte qui s'est passé dans les heures
qui ont précédé
c'est une attaque de lait des écoles ces
deux sites sont des violences avec des
feux des incendies et la police elle
essaye de maîtrise
ces jeunes garçons en leur faisant
comprendre que ça ne se fait pas c'est
aussi simple que ça c'est du simple bon
sens et le fait moi je ne suis pas
choqué par ce que je vois contrairement
aux mises de l'éducation at il
d'ailleurs il commence par dire je suis
choquée puis après il explique qu'il ya
pas de quoi être choqué et d'imagés
choquantes et après il la justifie ou en
tout cas ils l'expliquent par la part la
situation alors je vais vous dire le
fond de ma pensée je ne suis pas
spécialement choqué par par cette image
on a mis ces garçons là pour qu'ils
commencent à réfléchir pendant une
demi-heure une heure je ne sais pas sur
le bon ils ont été emmenés mais peu
importe je veux dire ils ont participé à
une manifestation violente dont ils en
subissent les conséquences
on peut pas demander aujourd'hui aux
gens de perdu la vue me dire oui mais
quand vous pédalez une manifestation
vous prenez un risque
vous prenez un risque non le droit de
manifester c'est un droit qui fait 40
cents par la domination le droit de
défiler ok mais le droit de manifester
violemment si vous en prenez violemment
aux forces de l'ordre et qu'elle s'en
prenne relativement violemment à vous je
vois pas où on est on est de légaliser
techniques de maintien de l'ordre
et il existe des instructions dans
matière de maintien de l'ordre qui font
que normalement un manifestant ne doit
pas se retrouver avec un oeil perdu
comme ça métier voilà en l'occurrence là
les cas qui sont cités aujourd'hui dans
les dents dans les dépêches qui sortent
avec des témoignages ce ne sont
absolument pas des émeutiers ce sont des
jeunes qui étaient là je vous passe à
part du terminator laddh réduit ce qui
met leur patient poubelles devant a
laissé ses pains et maintenant mais en
l'occurrence là il s'agit pas de ces
jeunes à leu leu
tony nous dit et quand les élèves
braquent leurs professeurs avec des
armes de poing
allusion évidemment à ce qui s'est passé
il ya quelques il ya quelques semaines
la corbeille sur twitter on va on vous a
posé la question est ce que vous êtes
choqués par ces images et c'est plutôt
non à 56 %
hervé nathan vous avez la fin moi je
suis choqué par les images soient si
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya eu une mise
en scène
voilà on a voulu me serais on a voulu
mettre en scène une défaite militaire on
avait voilà c'est le canton fait ça des
ennemis sur le champ de bataille c'est
ce qu'on fait à vos ennemis dans son
champ de bataille une certaine manière
pour ce qu'on fait des études classiques
et qui se souviennent des cours de ce
que faisaient les les rumeurs pour
l'heure les humilier leurs ennemis en
les faisant passer sous les fourches
caudines pour ceux qui se souviennent de
leurs cours d'histoire romaine de 6e 5e
et puis voilà voire pire mais une
certaine manière je vous signale je
signale qu'il ya une enquête
administrative pour savoir qui a tourné
parce que l'autre chose c'est qu'ils
semblent ce soit à membres des forces de
l'ordre qui est tourné les images pour
les diffuser et ce à une certaine
manière c'est répréhensible
voilà j box et condamne parce que
tourner en maintenant condamne toute
manière donc c'est vrai aussi pourquoi
parce que du coup ça pour moi ça ça ça
dit que effectivement c'est une mise en
scène on a voulu les mettre dans une
pose une minière qui ensuite on les a
filmés et on a diffusé ça je trouve que
c'est ta meuf c'est pas bien voilà on va
dire tout bêtement comme les enfants ni
bah c'est pas bien voilà et sera pas
directement de la bâtisse avait juste
merci à une [ __ ] d'accord a vraiment
un sale or pour le coup pour le coup
pour le coup si vous voulez que les
jeunes qui ont été humiliés de cette
façon-là rejoint les casseurs vous
faites ça là pour le coup il y en a cent
quarante-trois de plus parce qu'ils
étaient 147 donc peut-être qu'on en
avait quatre à l'intérieur qu'ils
méritaient de ce qui peut être combattue
regardent eux ils sont tous allés au
poste après alors parce qu'ils avaient
une possibilité c'était pas les mettre à
genoux c'était des faire s'asseoir
n'était pas obligé de voilà de mettre
tout ça en scène pour juste les garder
quelques quelques minutes ou voir un
petit peu plus pour les faire monter en
sus dans les paniers à salade et les
emmener au poste pour un contrôle
d'identité voir une garde à vue ce qui
est effectivement le droit de du
maintien de la domination collective un
peu comme on dit c'est qu'on sait à la
fois une punition plus électifs c'est
une humiliation et c'est une c'est un
message à l'extérieur effectivement qui
a dit
ça pourrait être un exemple pour demain
voilà une mère j'espère que demain nous
ne verrons pas ça intense qui est ce qui
est paradoxal c'est que alors il
faudrait mesurer précisément les choses
mais on a le sentiment que ces images
provoque beaucoup plus de commentaires
sur les réseaux sociaux que toutes les
images de violences contre les policiers
comme s'il y avait une forme
d'indignation un peu sélective et si le
problème des réseaux sociaux les images
sont tellement manipulé qu'on ne sait
plus qui a fait quoi dans quel but etc
etc
c'est comme ça que le paris match se
retrouvent cette semaine avec en
couverture un négationniste bien connu
qu'on porte parole des filets je veux
dire dans ce monde là afin moi c'est mon
milieu la télévision ce que je vois là
c'est quelque chose d'affreux là on
pouvait faire dire n'importe quoi à
n'importe qui à n'importe quel moment le
contraire de ce qui s'est fait peut-être
que là je me trompe vous tromper on ne
sait pas c'est une tierce personne qui
s'est dit je vais faire ça dans tel but
etc
je suis dit c'est quelque chose ça
quelque chose d'affolant d'affolant le
problème c'est que ce traitement la de
l'actualité il est inéluctable on part
on peut pas faire sans les réseaux
sociaux sont là les chaînes
d'information continue sont là et il
faut et il faut gérer avec las il prône
des chaînes d'information continue est
long vivent de ça elles ont besoin si
c'était un automobile je parlerai pas de
sentiments mais de gasoil toute la
journée d'information donc elles ont
besoin de ça regardez voyez comment les
présentateurs de ces chaînes sont
désemparés le matin il ne parle que de
la météo
il espère bien qu'à midi va se passer
quelque chose qui va enfin un bon
attentat une bonne bagarre etc mais
adhérence à 8h30 les chaînes le fond au
6 mars que l'audience est là ça veut
dire que les français aussi sont
intéressés par ces sujets prenez les
choses dans un sens ou dans l'autre il
ya vingt ans il y avait deux journaux
télévisés par jour il y en avait 1 13
heures et à 20 heures et on vivait on
était informé on n'était pas dans cet
état de stress permanent d'abord ça
permettait de sélectionner les images on
faisait pas on ne passait pas de
n'importe quoi je dis pas que c'était
mieux avant mais disons que c'était
moins stressant ce site est mort alors
très bien d'ailleurs j'en étais donc
merci beaucoup
avec ses 10 ans bernard est d'accord
avec cette métisse en principe oui
s'était perdu avant
voilà on s'éloigne un petit peu de la
france pour nous rendre jusqu en
allemagne angela merkel kit haut